when I first started working as a
journalist it was the adventure meeting
new people going to new places new
challenges to try to capture those
people in places or a specific wild
animal on film to try to get into the
heart and soul of that animal the lion
is one of the most beautiful powerful
creatures on earth and to see a wild
lion in a wild place dealing with the
elements and the Kalahari Desert Lions
of Africa are the most powerful biggest
strongest lions dealing in the harshest
landscape and the world and to see that
animal out dealing with the elements the
power behind an animal in such a wild
wild place is one of the great pleasures
of my life so then you try to capture
what you feel in what you see in in that
photograph I've been photographing Lions
for more than 12 years and I finally I
think started to get at how beautiful
how majestic and how strong the lion was
dealing with the elements he didn't
really pay very much attention to us it
was getting to be dark and he was just
he was seeking shelter as he walked
through the Kalahari in this I wind and
virtually all the pictures didn't turn
out because it was starting to get dark
the wind was blowing in my Land Rover
was rocking was frustrated cuz I kept
bumping into rocks and bashing around it
as it often does just came down to one
for him